- [Mark] If there's something
strange in the neighborhood,
- Who you gonna call?
- [Mark] Well, with all due
respect to the Ghostbusters,
if I'm being attacked by
a spook, specter, ghost,
or a free-floating, full-torsoed,
vaporous apparition,
I'm not calling four
graduate school dropouts.
No, I'm either dialing up
the Winchester brothers
or I'm gassing up The Mystery Machine.
- Scooby and the gang.
These guys, they're our
freaking role models, man,
except Fred, he's a wad.
Today it's "Scooby-Doo"
versus "Supernatural"
for the crown of the
all-time best battlers
of the bellowing blight.
Scooby-Doo, Shaggy, and the gang
have been a worldwide institution
for generations of fans.
Meanwhile, Sam and Dean
Winchester have cultivated
an impressive 15-year run,
thanks to a legion of die-hard supporters.
Whether the enemy du jour
is ghosts, werewolves,
or Mr. Withers, who runs
the old amusement park,
these two teams of lovable underdogs
always get the job done.
But what happens when they
face off against each other?
Zoinks!
Here's how we'll determine a winner.
Round one, Tomatometer.
Round two, popularity.
Round three, characters.
And then we'll do a wild card round
to settle the score once and for all.
I'll then say goodnight,
then it's up to you,
the home viewer, to cast your vote.
The mystery gang is taking
on the Winchester family
and a whole box of Scooby
Snacks are on the line.
I once ate a Milk-Bone on a dare.
Let's get it on!
- The most beautiful words in the world!
All you can eat.
- Clear eyes and the clogged
arteries, can't lose.
- [Mark] Round one: Tomatometer.
Everyone, and their mother,
and their grandmother,
and their great-grandma's ghost
has heard of "Scooby-Doo,"
and "Supernatural" has
enough hardcore fans
to populate an entire country.
But how do the critics feel
about these celebrated franchises?
- Pull my finger, uh-oh, too late!
- [Mark] Okay, Winchesters,
y'all wanna take a crack
at this one first?
The boys and their gaggle
of relatives, friends,
and spooky enemies appear to
be BFFS with the Tomatometer.
But whether you've never
heard of "Supernatural"
or you're a hardcore fan,
you're gonna need to brace yourself
because the show has an
overall average of 93 percent.
- What?
- [Mark] And that's not
like out of a thousand,
that's out of a hundred,
that's an A average, kids!
The show's lowest season
was scored at 63 percent,
which is still Fresh,
and the show can boast
multiple perfect seasons at 100 percent,
including its currently
ongoing 15th season.
Wait, so the current
season is still perfect?
Okay, nobody talk to it in the dugout.
Leave it alone, do not jinx this.
- We got work to do.
- [Mark] You may be saying to yourself,
"Okay, Mark, you handsome hunk of granite,
"93 percent is good, but
'Scooby-Doo' is beloved."
Right?
Well, not necessarily by the critics.
So we don't have Tomatometer scores
for the original CBS or
ABC runs of the show,
but we do have them for
the more recent live-action
and animated features, and
it only averages 50 percent.
50 percent?
In what twisted world
could you possibly rate
a ghost-fighting dog Rotten?
Despite sizeable box office success,
it appears the live-action films
starring Matthew Lillard,
Linda Cardellini,
Sarah Michelle Gellar, and
my close personal friend,
Freddie Prinze Jr, are considered Rotten!
They average just 26 percent.
However, a handful of the
animated films are Fresh,
with "Scooby-Doo on Zombie Island"
taking the top franchise
score at 86 percent.
And that movie came out, like, a decade
before "The Walking Dead," so Scooby,
you were ahead of the curve.
♪ Do you hear the screeching of an owl ♪
♪ Do you hear the wind begin ♪
- [Mark] So despite the
mystery gang's good looks
and sense of humor, it's the other sect
of funny hunks that's gonna
take round number one.
"Supernatural" has a good
enough Tomatometer score
to get into an Ivy League school,
and that's why it's going
up one-nothing on Scooby.
♪ Eye of the tiger, it's
the thrill of the fight ♪
♪ Rising up ♪
- [Mark] Round two: popularity.
To all the kids out there watching,
being popular, it's not a big deal.
Follow your own path, march to
the beat of your own drummer.
Unless, of course, you're
trying to win a round
of this show, then being cool
and lovable really helps.
- Keeping it real.
- [Mark] I mentioned the
mystery team's foibles
as it pertains to critics
on the Tomatometer,
but Scooby does rebound
when it comes to the audience score.
Him and the gang make it
into Fresh territory, barely,
at 62 percent.
However, "Supernatural" continues
its sterling Fresh record
with a healthy B average of 86 percent.
And, according to the
audience, between seasons three
and five of the show,
"Supernatural" enjoyed
a three-year high of 95 percent.
Meanwhile, the two series,
"What's New, Scooby-Doo?"
and "Shaggy & Scooby-Doo Get a Clue!"
each have a perfect 100 percent,
although 2018's "Daphne &
Velma" only garnered 37 percent.
Why is that so low?
I like "Daphne & Velma,"
did Scrappy-Doo show up
and ruin it?
More on you in the next round, ugh.
- People adore me!
- Popularity can also be
determined by a question
as simple as, "Does
anyone watch your show?"
Sam, Dean, and the gang
certainly have solid ratings
that strengthen their case.
For the first 14 seasons
of "Supernatural,"
it averaged 2.35 million
viewers per episode,
and that's all the more
impressive considering
it originally aired on The CW,
and not one of the major networks.
Fans were onboard with the
brothers from the start
as season one set a show
record of 3.81 million viewers
per week.
However, many more fans, like yours truly,
didn't really discover the
greatness of "Supernatural"
until it was available on
streaming platforms like Netflix.
As a matter of fact, I think
the first time I saw it,
I had a DVD mailed to me by Netflix.
I miss the medieval times.
- Our one chance!
- Isn't that the speech from--
- It's the only one he knows.
- [Mark] "Scooby-Doo"
obviously goes way further back
into human and dog history.
The show debuted in 1969
and has been in the public
consciousness ever since.
And even though the ratings
for all the various
incarnations of "Scooby"
are murky at best,
I can report that in 1969,
65 percent of households
were tuned into CBS on Saturday morning,
where it originally aired.
That's gonna sell a lot of
Anacin and talcum powder.
- Scooby-Doo!
- [Mark] "Scooby" does have the advantage
of having been on the big screen,
churning out two live-action hits early on
in this millennium.
"Scooby-Doo" and its sequel,
"Monsters Unleashed,"
combined for an impressive 384
million dollars domestically
and 740 million dollars worldwide.
Apparently people love dogs
and their stoned owners.
Furthering the case
for The Mystery Machine
is the Cartoon Network phenomenon.
Check this, "Scooby-Doo! The
Mystery Begins" premiered
in 2009 and broke virtually
every record that channel had.
It got 6 million viewers!
Then, the next year, its follow-up,
"Curse of the Lake Monster,"
garnered 5 million views.
Both were good for the number
one telecast of the year
on Cartoon Network.
Sure, it's a bit of a lopsided battle,
having a TV show battle another TV show
that also has movies, but
maybe there is a reason
"Scooby" got to be on the silver
screen in the first place.
But before I give up on the
Winchesters in this round,
let's see how many episodes they've made.
Uh, wow, really?
327 "Supernatural" shows
will have been made
by the end of the run.
I've never done 327 of
anything in my life.
Well, that one thing.
- Dude.
Were you on my computer?
- Other than that, but look,
"Scooby-Doo" can even
top that gaudy number,
because his gang has 376
episodes over 16 different shows,
five animated TV films, two
theatrically released movies,
42 animated direct-to-DVD films,
six direct-to-DVD specials,
three direct-to-DVD live-action
movies, 35 web shorts,
537 comic book issues,
(sighing)
okay.
We get the point.
Scooby's popular, and he gets a snack,
because his squad wins round number two.
Scooby
dooby
doo!
- [Mark] Round three: characters.
So many legendary starred
characters and role-players
to consider here, I might
need more time to think.
- I don't know, gang.
Sounds like this could be
the start of a mystery.
- [Mark] Okay, so where do we begin?
Let's get the core
starters involved first.
Sam, Dean, you guys are up.
Jared Padalecki and Jensen Ackles
have the kind of chemistry that scientists
in lab coats crave.
They play off each other so well
even when they're having
fun introducing themselves
under any of their myriad pseudonyms.
- I'm Dean Winchester, I'm
looking for the Devil's son,
this badge is fake.
- [Mark] They even used fake monikers
referencing Van Halen and Metallica,
so you know that's an easy
early point for "Supernatural"
in this round.
Whether it's their powerful bro-hugs,
their willingness to sacrifice
themselves for each other,
or just karaoke perfection,
♪ Straightenin' the curves ♪
- [Mark] Sam and Dean make
for amazingly sturdy anchors
of the show.
♪ I'm wanted ♪
♪ Wanted ♪
- [Mark] But Scooby-Doo
and Shaggy are icons.
They debuted in the Summer of Love,
and audiences all over the world
have been swooned ever since.
Scooby's plucky optimism meshes so well
with Shaggy's fearful reluctance,
and the two always meet in the middle
with their common love of food.
(quirky music)
(sniffing)
(sighing)
But let's not forget the other trio
who spent decades in the
hallowed Mystery Machine:
Fred, Velma, and Daphne.
Fred takes his role of
being a nerd do-good-er
dressed like a preppy frat boy in stride,
and he loves splitting up.
It's like his favorite pastime.
Daphne and Velma, when
their unique abilities
as amateur detectives, and, all told,
the gang has rounded up a
grand total of 392 villains.
Yeah, I counted.
I, I have that kind of
free time these days.
"Supernatural" has also had a
blast introducing characters
who expanded from
becoming mere role-players
into regularly occurring cast members.
How about Castiel's
entrance in season four?
- Hey, ass-butt.
- [Mark] Mary Winchester
and John Winchester
also factor prominently, and
the show is further bolstered
by memorable turns from
famous people like Felicia Day
and Sterling K. Brown.
Then you have the characters
that surround the mystery gang.
(sighs) Okay, here's the good news, first.
Memorable cameos had been
a staple of "Scooby-Doo"
since the beginning.
Everyone from The Monkees to Mama Cass
to the Harlem Globetrotters
have enjoyed the company
of Scooby and Norville.
Did you know that was, that
was Shaggy's real name, was,
was Norville?
I'd probably go by Shaggy too.
But look, I can't let the
mystery gang off the hook
that easy, there's an
elephant in the room,
and it's Scooby's nephew.
- Scrappy dappy doo!
- [Mark] To put it gently,
not well-liked.
I myself have a confounding
relationship with Scrappy
because, as a kid, I thought he was great,
he was maybe my favorite
character on the show.
And then, you know, I became an adult,
and, the thing is, seeing
"Scooby-Doo" as an adult,
I watched the show and I was saying,
"Scrappy is the most annoying character
"I've ever seen in my life."
It's hard to make me not like a dog!
It's like Scrappy-Doo
and what other hated dog
is there, ever?
I was even cool with
Poochie from "The Simpsons."
The Taco Bell chihuahua, sure.
Scrappy-Doo, no thank you.
There was also a
Scooby-Dum and a Dooby-Doo,
which I'm pretty sure
Shaggy tried to smoke.
Overall, it's a tough call here,
but there's no contest
in terms of role-players.
"Supernatural" has solid
contributors coming off the bench
every season, and they
never had a Scrappy-Doo.
I'm trying to think of any
other dog that I disliked.
Even the replacement Brian on "Family Guy"
at least had a funny line here or there.
But if we're looking at
a truly iconic core cast,
you can't ignore the staying power
of Fred, Daphne, Velma,
Shaggy, and, of course, Scooby.
They're underrated as detectives,
and even if they aren't
as cool as Sam and Dean,
they're endlessly entertaining to watch.
In the tightest round yet,
I'm gonna give the win
to Scooby and the gang,
and they're up two to one.
♪ This is how we solve the mystery ♪
Bye.
- [Mark] Wild card round: villains.
Okay, I know what you're thinking,
Mark, don't villains
just count as characters?
Technically yes, but the big baddies
are such an integral part of both shows
that they deserve their own category.
(whooping)
- That was scary!
- [Mark] The name of
the show "Supernatural"
says it all.
You got your classic ghosts
and ghouls, vampires,
werewolves, but there's
also really freaky stuff
that I'm glad I never heard
of when I was a child.
How about the darkness?
No, this is not "The Thing Called Love,"
in fact, it's the older sister of God.
Yeah, of God!
And she ain't happy her little
bro gets all the credit.
You got the horsemen of the apocalypse,
leviathans, djinns, who
I actually had heard of
thanks to Magic: The Gathering.
What's really cool about each
villain that they take on
is the backstory that we get.
The nod to mythology is one
of the most intriguing aspects
of "Supernatural."
You get the siren or the crocotta,
which mimics human voices
to draw in its prey.
And this isn't to mention
all the other demons,
you got your changelings,
you got your hell hounds,
the Winchesters have had
to deal with these things
on a regular basis.
- Listen, Velma, this
isn't the Scooby gang.
- [Mark] So how does "Scooby-Doo" answer?
Well, look, you may think "Scooby-Doo"
is just a kid-friendly show,
but listen to this roster of baddies.
Apeman, viking ghost, no-faced
zombie, phantom virus!
Hey, that's topical.
And you also had your
sillier variety like Catman,
ghost clown, the Loch Ness Monster,
which actually turned
out to be a vehicle, eh.
The big obstacle the mystery
gang faces in this round
is the lack of a recurring threat.
"Supernatural" had some all-time baddies
coming back for more.
Crowley vacillated between
villain and anti-hero
but was always a captivating watch.
And Lilith eventually reached her goal
of destroying the 66 locks
keeping Lucifer at bay.
And Lucifer himself, well,
as you might imagine,
he tortured poor Sam so much,
he had to go to the psych ward!
The only real counter
"Scooby" has in this round
is if we, the audience, can
consider Scrappy-Doo a villain.
I think a lot of people out there would.
He's certainly a show ruiner,
but he did try his best.
Okay, fine, Scrappy, you're not a villain,
but you're just super annoying.
The reason I respect both squads
of demon-deflecting detectives
is their continued ability
to take on cases no one else would.
Most humans and-or canines
would be too afraid
to battle any of these creatures,
and that's only if they even
believed in them at all.
- I'm gonna go stop the big bad wolf,
which is the weirdest
thing I've ever said.
- [Mark] The mystery gang and
the Winchesters had the faith
to fight the scariest things
on Earth or elsewhere.
The big difference is that Scooby's team
usually found out the big
scary thing they were facing
was just some old town kook,
some older fella who didn't like
the last meal government
cheese the city served him
and so he decided to get revenge,
and he would have gotten away with it,
if it wasn't for you meddling kids!
- Hey, we're not kids!
- The meddlesome kids named Sam
and Dean, on the other hand,
they fought the scariest
actual villains imaginable,
and that's why they get the
win in the wild card round.
The Winchesters take it,
and it's all tied up at two.
- You know what?
You're awesome.
- And now we're at the
point in the show where I,
your fearless host,
has to render a verdict
and break this tie.
But first, did you know
about the legendary cross-over-ish
episode of "Supernatural"
that involves Scooby-Doo and his team?
(exclaiming)
- You're a cartoon!
- I'm a cartoon!
- [Mark] They call it the
"Scoobynatural" episode
and one of the many highlights
is that we get to see
sort of a showdown between
two celebrated vehicles.
So the Winchesters, they
have their '67 Chevelle,
it's a classic, and if you're a gear-head,
you know that thing can
pack some serious punch.
But it actually gets outran
by The Mystery Machine
in that episode.
So maybe the van was powered
by unwavering optimism
or a nitrous oxide boost,
but it did win the race.
So is that enough to give
"Scooby-Doo" the win today?
Okay, look, both teams
deserve our respect.
They've outlasted countless
witches and ghosts
and the most ridiculous
monsters you could think of.
And they managed to
entertain us consistently
in the process.
They're both titans of the
world of the supernatural,
but only one can be called truly iconic.
Scooby-Doo and his pals
have been crushing the game
for more than 50 years,
and they've entertained us all
from the time we were wee little tykes,
all the way through our adult years.
In a recent survey,
Ranker listed Scooby-Doo
as the number one greatest
cartoon character in history!
Now, I'm a fan of Sam and Dean,
but could they have taken
down the likes of Bugs Bunny
or Homer Simpson?
I don't think so.
I think even hardcore
defenders of "Supernatural"
will admit that we all
owe a tip of the cap
or a tug of the ascot to the mystery gang.
- Take a bullet for that dog.
- Without them, generations of kids
may never have gotten as
invested in supernatural lore,
and who knows if any of
these other shows or movies
that we take for granted today
would have gotten made.
- Hey, did you believe me when I said
I thought we could win this thing?
No?
- Hold the phone.
- Jeepers.
- Jinkies.
- Zoinks?
- Okay, so "Scooby-Doo" gets the win,
but that's just our
opinion, now it's your turn,
head to the comments right
now and vote for who you think
is the best supernatural
poltergeist babblers of all time.
Okay, we're gonna say
goodnight to everybody.
Keep wearing those ascots.
Somebody wants a Scooby Snack.
We'll see you next time here on the show.
Like, zoinks, Scoob!
(upbeat music)